Presidente Trump wants to build a wall,
and he would like Mexico to pay for it.
Would you like to make a donation?
Do you have any?
Would you like to put a?
Put here love.
Love?
You'd put love in there?
And kindness.
No I need cash.
(audience laughs)
Would you like to donate to the wall?
Oh.
And I'm gonna sweeten the deal.
If you donate 500 pesos,
you get your name on a brick in the wall.
Oh really?
Yeah!
Okay, and you have to act now,
cause there's only gonna be 800 million of these.
Oh really?
Yeah!
For 1000 pesos, look at this,
you get an I paid for the wall tote bag.
Do you want that, see?
Oh my God.
And throwing in, look at this right here.
Muchas Gracias.
Yes, that's how he spells it.
Does he want to donate money to build the wall that Trump?
Eh, no.
(laughing)
Is there anything you'd like to say to President Trump?
If you speak in Spanish, Trump won't understand.
If you speak in English he may not understand.
Hola, como estas?
Bien!
Alright, how are you?
Hi!
I wanna hug the grandmother, please!
(crowd cheers)
Donate?
No, no.
He promised, he said Mexico would pay!
Trump said that you would pay.
No.
He said you would pay!
Not pay nothing.
Trump said you would pay.
I put this.
No you can't, no, you can't!
(cheering and applause)
Mexico, Mexico, Mexico!